Matthew,
you ask one of the most embarrassing and
deepest theological questions at the
merger at the,
at the area where physics and philosophy
collide at the present time.
We can only teleport photons,
particles of light,
and Adam's like caesium in rubidium.
That's it for the present time.
However,
in the coming years,
we do expect to be able to teleport
molecules,
maybe water,
carbon dioxide after that,
who knows,
maybe even Dna,
maybe organic molecules.
Now,
to teleport a human raises all the
ethical questions that you mentioned
because the original,
first of all,
it has to be destroyed in the process of
quantum teleportation.
So if you get captain Kirk Zap them
across the room,
you have now seen captain Kirk die.
You've seen this.
Adam's fall apart.
But here's this other Captain Clark on
the other side of the room who has the
same bad jokes,
who has the same character?
All the personality quirks as the
original Captain Kirk.
So the imposter says,
no,
I'm real.
I have the memories,
the personality,
the courts,
uh,
am captain Kirk.
Well,
you just saw the original die and if you
believe in a soul,
that soul went to heaven or maybe the
other place,
but that person is dead.
So who is this imposter over there that
the imposter have a soul?
So it raises the question,
are we nothing but information is the
soul the essence of who we are?
Nothing but information.
Well,
I'm a physicist.
We don't know the answer to that.
All we're saying is it is physically
possible to teleport and entire human
being across the room or maybe onto
Mars.
It is physically possible to do that.
And it raises a valid question.
What happened to the soul?
If you original copy died and somebody
out there has all your memories,
what does that mean?
And the answer is we don't know.